right one of the reasons why the
Dolphins may not have traded down to try
to get to a Tonga by llola who knows
what the charges would have done at
number six if both Toa and Justin
Herbert were available tool wasn't
Justin was Justin becomes the pick and
you know Chris the first thing I thought
of is well there surely is no way
they're gonna sign Cam Newton now it's
Tyrod Taylor in the same spot he was in
two years ago in Cleveland holding the
position until the rookie is ready and
it didn't take long for Baker Mayfield
to supplant Tyrod Taylor in Cleveland in
2018
now Justin Herbert ready to go whenever
the Chargers decide to flip the switch
from Tyrod Taylor to the rookie from
Oregon and go yeah I don't have to go
far from Oregon right no he doesn't
bubble he doesn't have to go all that
far well you see you know teams are
aware of that you know yeah this is a
pac-12 kid right to uh you know down in
Miami it's not far from the SEC country
how about CD lamb to the Dallas Cowboys
oh yeah Oklahoma's right down the road
so that's a very real aspect and
drafting some of these players knowing
that there's a following in the region
around these players that are gonna
bring what play you know fans and people
to your stadium because they're gonna go
man I saw this kid in college or I
always wanted to watch a play in college
and now he's here on my pro team but
yeah Herbert I think the world of them I
really do I think he's super talented
smart you know the things that I think
people nitpick about him as a player I
think are more to do with the organ
offense the team around them but as far
as athleticism sighs big-time arm
hey decision makings good was it perfect
no but I think when he gets in the NFL
and gets coached a little bit better and
has a more creative offense around a man
this could be special and the big thing
is to Mike you know men you know you
just think of the Chargers right now
this defense they get Kenneth Murray you
know down in the 20s the linebacker from
Oklahoma and this is Super Bowl defense
we got right now in Los Angeles with
those pass rushers Derwin James Chris
Harris jr. you know in the offseason I
mean this is a talented group
and we know they want to run the ball
yes they have Tyrod Taylor but you know
when you drop the guy at number six he
has a few good preseason games or so is
training camp this is going to be the
starter and if they want to run the ball
and play defense and and control the
clock a little Justin Herbert's gonna be
capable of doing that in year one so you
know I would not be shocked if we saw
him in there as the starting quarterback
at some point early in the season if not
just to start the season well they do
have that flexibility in luxury now and
the other reality is to the extent the
Chargers need stars Herbert is going to
get the chance to be that star in LA and
look at him in his Chargers t-shirt when
he was I don't know I'd say maybe four
years old his hair got a lot darker as
he got older and it was his glorious
then as it is now and Chris I don't know
if you saw it at one point last night
there was a picture of young Justin
Herbert in his Joey Harrington Jersey
for the judges sake let's hope the
ceiling is higher for Justin Herbert's
for Justin Herbert than it was for his
boyhood idol so that was fun to see and
Justin's a good kid and and I hope it
goes well for him the Chargers need
someone long-term to develop into that
star player or they're never gonna have
a chance in the LA market yeah well yes
and I think they they got a quarterback
here that got as much upside as any
quarterback in the draft I mean he has
superstar qualities he does when you
talk about a guy that big who can move
the way he can and then I mean don't get
him mixed up this is a laser for a right
arm I mean a big-time arm this will be
one of the best arms in the NFL from
get-go when he steps onto the field and
you know I yeah you know to me this is a
guy that was over evaluated in the draft
process saying you know too much made
about always never left Eugene Oregon oh
he doesn't you know he's not a Yeller
he's got a rah-rah type leader you know
those things can be developed I'm not
worried about that you know and even the
things that I saw in the field that
weren't always perfect you know I think
you put him at LSU or put him in Alabama
with some of those offenses and talent
around him his game would have looked a
lot smoother last year so this is a
great pick by the Chargers I mean this
is a big-time quarterback
I think when they saw him on the board
still there at number six I just don't
think they could pass it up
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports